- It kinda sounds French.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Koshary
- Oh Koshary
- Oh Koshary ooh.
- Ooh la la.
- Koshary.
(middle eastern music)
- Wow I really don't
know a lot about Egypt.
Not to mention their food.
I don't know what their food could be.
- King Tut, is that?
- There's pyramids.
Yeah he was there, yeah.
- King Tut.
- Is there gonna be falafel and stuff?
No?
- [Man] No.
- Yes!
Oh this looks so good!
- Oooh!
- Ooh, what is this, onion?
- Oh yes.
- Oh my God, I love fried onion.
- Mmm.
- Mm.
- Mmhmm.
- Oh my God.
- Yep, yep.
I could eat this everyday.
- I never thought about
mixing rice and pasta.
- Yeah.
- I used to do that on
accident when I drop it but,
here it's just delicious.
- [Blonde Woman] We're
about to eat Hawawshi.
- Hawawshi.
- It's like how is she?
Hawawshi.
- Wow.
- Yeah this is really good.
- This is how wow.
- Wow!
- Wow.
- I kinda wanna dip it in something.
- Yeah I wish there was dip to this.
- [Man In Glasses] Molokhia.
- Molokhia.
- It's like you're hawking a loogie.
- Hia.
- Ooooh!
- Oh.
- It looks like it would be Molokhia.
- Yeah.
(middle eastern music)
- I don't know, it's just like there's
a layer or grease on top of it.
- It tastes really good but like,
the moment it touches your lips
it goes all over your lips.
- Yeah it makes like a,
it doubles as a lip balm.
- Ali's mom.
- Is it like mother's milk?
(laughs)
- I love this.
This is like heaven on earth.
- It tastes like old cereal.
- I love old cereal.
- My mom wants to fatten me
up, she can make this yeah.
- Umm Ali's my favorite.
- Umm Ali sounds like
a really cool rapper.
- I would absolutely have this again.
- Me too.
- Yeah I could totally
see a huge dinner table
and everything is
portioned off family style
and you're like passing it down,
you scoop a little bit of this,
you scoop a little bit of that.
Yeah, it's great, I liked it.
(hinge squeaks)